let's bring in Jerry for our friend of
the show course entourage from 2004 to
2011 Think Like a Man Las Vegas he's got
a podcast called bad for business and
he's Jerry Ferrara who joins us now I
came across this story on fortnight with
these younger NBA players and they're
spending you know five seven ten hours
playing for tonight explain the
phenomenon to those of us who haven't
played it you know it really and that's
exactly what it is this is a phenomenon
and what I think that it the reason why
people are taking to it first of all
they do like a cross-platform thing
which is not really something that's
normal which means if you have an Xbox
or a Playstation or a PC now it doesn't
matter you could play with everyone so
really opens it up where it used to be
like Xbox can only play what Xbox then
there's a really popular streamer named
ninja who had a stream on fortnight with
Drake and juju Smith Schuster and Travis
Scott that broke the internet and ever
since then it's just been off and
running I mean you look every day and
there's some athlete or some high school
player a college player doing fortnight
dances it really is a phenomenon and
another thing about they think it's like
bridge the gap between like young and
old like I play with like my 16 year old
cousins it's like reintroduced our
relationship now so it's it's it's a
heck of a game it brings people together
as what you're saying and by the way
this this dude named ninja
he makes five hundred thousand dollars
playing fortnight he shared so people
watch him play fortnight just to get
tips hints on how to be good at this
yes so it's kind of cute fold one he is
unbelievable at the game so he's able to
do things that not many people could do
in the game and number two he's also
highly highly entertaining to watch so
you're watching him play and then you're
also getting some entertainment and then
like I said you know he got so popular
that one day he just tweeted out like
he's streaming with Drake and and juju
Smith and it's just I mean yes he is
making that amount of money and I think
it's great for the gaming community now
it's it's I mean we're talking about it
on your show
I'm so happy when when Paulie reached
out so you guys want to talk about it's
mainstream I love it
I like that Josh Hart broke his left
hand he's a place for the the Lakers so
he had to play fortnight you know he he
only had one hand to play fortnight
there but he said he was obsessed with
this how about this he said that he he
can one session spanned until at least
4:00 in the morning with a one o'clock
tip-off for the next day I mean via dick
you know these guys used to go to the
club staring now they're just like
hanging together playing fortnight no
and wouldn't you think that if you're
you know in management of a team that
you kind of love this you know okay like
your players are now night clubs maybe
feel foreign to more into playing sport
now when you rather them at home doing I
think they might encourage it and then I
saw another I saw Gordon Hayward I think
it last now today or something like his
daughter walk his little daughter walked
in on them and almost got them
eliminated from a game so I know
karl-anthony towns is a pretty big
player I think Reggie Jackson it just as
I think that's been the thing it bridged
the gap between like gamers who are
professionals and and pro athletes it's
awesome but is it it was described to me
as Hunger Games where you have a hundred
people on a map and it's a survival game
is that right where you find supplies
weapons materials yes so you drop in on
a map and you are basically like skydive
out of the out of the battle bus and as
soon as you get down it's like every man
for himself you're running you're
scavenging you're gathering materials
and weapons and all that and the good
thing about it's you that I love is I'm
not very good so for me a game is like
if I go seven eight minutes I'm like I
did okay so you're not sitting there for
45 minutes in one game you could play
three games in a half-hour and my wife
could yell at me to stop and I feel like
I I got in some time so I think also
that's a big a big thing with the game
the phenomenon of eSports does it how
does it go to the next level
I think it's already there I mean you
know another game called overwatch had a
professional league that did really well
I am literally consulting for Knicks
gaming as they start an NBA 2k league
I'm their consultant and executive scout
like I have today after this I have to
go sit down and call 50 of the hundred
and two players who are getting drafted
on April 4th so it's like my it's like
the only way I'll ever get any kind of a
DM I'm watching footage of these pro
players on 2k and there's gonna be a
huge draft and 102 of these players are
gonna some six of them are gonna get
drafted to New York City get contracts
get health insurance like my mom's
proudest day was when I got my own
health insurance it's I think it's
already happening these competitive
leagues now and live events are really
becoming like sporting events and also
you have such a young crowd I think a
lot of sponsors are eager to be involved
because it's the 18 to 30 year old what
about calling them Call of Duty and
World of Warcraft and Halo or they all
pass a well no I mean they all have
their audience but League of Legends is
is a humongous title because also you
know some of these titles not only in
America but they reach into to Asia to
Europe so if that's the other thing that
makes this a phenomenon it's not just
domestic if anything it's even more
international than domestic so league of
legends is up there Call of Duty
certainly is always up there and those
like halo Call of Duty are sort of to me
and we those are the games that like
paved the way for all the stuff where
we're seeing today can you play video
games when you get to be 40 you know
I'll tell you what it's certainly hard
you know I don't I don't have any kids
yet I do feel like once that step
happens it's kind of [ __ ] real hard I'm
hanging on by a thread DPI man like I
was gonna suggest maybe you guys get a
setup in the man cave I'd love to see
the Dan that's on a fortnight's tree and
that would be epic I think your audience
would really really enjoy it that might
be the only way to do it is find a way
to have it at work somewhere so you can
maybe sneak off and take a break but uh
it does get harder I'm 38 my days are
numbered I'm doing F that's why like
this mixed gaming thing is great for me
because now I've turned a bit to a job
that's that's great that's great how
long would it take us though to get the
basics down for fortnight uh you get the
basics down three quick what what really
starts to happen is and the jump from
just getting the basics of getting
really really good that's what takes a
lot of time and practice but yeah I play
with my nine-year-old nephew and he's
already better than me and it's only
been like a month so uh yeah I'd love to
see McLovin and friends I'd love to see
you guys Hunger Games style on four at
night because you got to settle a lot of
beef that way could you imagine turtle
on Entourage with fortnight yeah Johnny
Drama you know we did that episode years
ago with the boxing game with Fight
Night yeah my character competed you
know semi-professionally so uh yeah I
think absolutely that's what I mean
that's what those guys somewhere a
turtle and drama are playing for at
night and doing some other things right
right as we speak somewhere those guys
are doing that hey Jerry it's good to
talk to you and hopefully we'll cross
paths soon oh wait I mean I'm in New
York DC so let's let's do it and I'm
coming for the bracket neck here oh you
are good yes well you know what I will
have last place with your name on it I
should get something for that thank you
thank you Jerry talking about this topic
all right Jerry Ferrara for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show ass
[Music]